THE SENATE WILL BE CALLED TO
ORDER. THE SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO
GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ATKINS
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. DALLY DODD.
DURAZO. EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ.
GROVE HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN.
NEWMAN WAYNE. NILO. OCHOA. BOGH
PADILLA. PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
SEYARTO. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG WAHAB.
WIENER. WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. GOOD MORNING.
EVERYONE SHH! WOULD THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY? PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR UMBERG. AFTER
WHICH, PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. TODAY'S PRAYER IS
FROM GUERRILLAS OF GRACE.
MERCIFUL GOD, THANK YOU FOR EACH
MOMENT. FOR THE CHARGED MOMENT.
THE CONFRONTATION, THE ACCURATE
DEMAND FOR THE HARD DECISION,
THE BREATHLESS GAMBLE, THE
UNEXPECTED GROWING FOR MY
INTENSE HEART AND THE TRUTH
EXPANDING IN ME FOCUSED ME TO BE
OPEN TO WHATEVER COMES AS A GIFT
AND TO PRAISE YOU IN IT. AMEN.
AMEN MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH OUR SENATE AGENDA.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'LL
MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. MEMBERS
THERE ARE FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT
THE DESK. THEY WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
29.1, SEE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. FILE ITEM 19 AB 1034.
FILE ITEM 34 AB 224. MEMBERS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL ADOPT
THE FLOOR AMENDMENTS SUBMITTED
BY THE AUTHOR OF THE MEASURE TO
BE AMENDED AND ACCOMPANIED BY A
POLICY COMMITTEE. AMEND
ANALYSIS. THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
BE PUBLISHED AND THE MEASURES
ORDERED TO SECOND READING. NEXT,
WANT TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
GONZALEZ? THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES. PLEASE.
I'M GOING TO DEFER. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, WE'RE GOING TO DEFER
YOUR YOUR MOTIONS FOR JUST A FEW
MINUTES. SENATOR UMBERG, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RETURN. SB 336 TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION. THE
DESK WILL NOTE ANYTHING ELSE
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL GO TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. WE'LL BEGIN
WITH THE SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2086 6015 11 2368, 26, OH
SIX, 28, 30, 31, 23, 30, 63, 32,
84, 27, 73, 27, 11 WILL BE
DEEMED READ. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
WITH TWO OF THEM PRESENTED BY
SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR GROVE,
THIS IS FILE ITEM 52. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, FILE
ITEM 52 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DARIUS ANDERSON FOR THE
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION. MR.
ANDERSON IS THE FOUNDER OF
SONOMA MEDIA INVESTMENTS,
PLATINUM ADVISORS, KENWOOD
INVESTMENTS AND A WING AND A
BARREL RANCH. HE PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNOR. GOVERNORS. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST 7TH ON A50 VOTE, AND
YES, THIS IS THE ORIGINAL MR.
DARIUS ANDERSON. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GROVE, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS NOMINATION?
ON THIS APPOINTMENT? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALL VOTED. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY DODD. AYE.
DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MEN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO
ASK EVERYONE TO KEEP IT A LITTLE
BIT LOWER VOLUME SO THAT THE
CLERK CAN HEAR THE VOTES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE OPS
AND MEMBERS. ATKINS, BECKER.
BRADFORD. DALLEY MENGIBAR. YILO.
KROBO RUBIO. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WAHAB. GALLEON DALEI. ON
A VOTE OF 30 TO 0, THE NOMINEE
IS CONFIRMED. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 53,
SENATOR GROVE. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
53 IS A CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING REGIONAL WATER CONTROL
BOARD APPOINTMENTS. DOCTOR
JEAN-PIERRE WOLFF FOR THE
CENTRAL COAST BOARD, NICHOLAS
AVITUS AND MARK BRADFORD FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BOARD. NO
RELATION TO SENATOR BRADFORD AND
MUSIC TO THE COLORADO RIVER
BASIN BOARD. RYAN SUNDBERG TO
THE NORTH COAST BOARD AND SEEKS
TO LOPEZ AND WILLIAM ROUX TO THE
SANTA ANA BOARD. THEY WERE ALL
APPROVED ON THE RULE BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST 7TH IN
A50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE NOMINEE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEAR AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
ECKMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN YILO.
KROBO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER SMILED. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
BECKER BRADFORD. DALLEY AYE.
GROVE. AYE. JONES. AYE. MENGIBAR
WAYNE. AYE. MILO. CARILLO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WAHAB.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE LAST TIME.
ATKINS BECKER. BRADFORD
MENGIBAR. MILO HIGH. OKOBOJI
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WAHAB.
ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 0, THE
NOMINEES ARE CONFIRMED. MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. THERE ARE
TWO ITEMS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE
ITEM 61 AND 68. WE'LL BEGIN WITH
FILE ITEM 61 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 689 BY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. MY BILL, SB 689, IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AFTER
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY. THE
BILL ORIGINALLY CLARIFIED AND
SIMPLIFIED THE PROCESS FOR
CITIES IN THE COASTAL ZONE TO
CONVERT A VEHICLE LANE TO A BIKE
LANE. THE AMENDMENTS EXPAND THE
BILL TO APPLY A CONSISTENT
PROCESS. WHEN A CITY IS SEEKING
CONVERSION OF VEHICLE LANES TO
PEDESTRIAN WALKWAYS AND
DEDICATED BIKE LANES, OR, EXCUSE
ME, DEDICATED BUS LANES. IN
ADDITION TO BIKE LANES. WE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION ON THESE CHANGES AND
THEY'RE IN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALL
VOTED. GILL ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. MEN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. NO. TROBO PADILLA.
PORTANTINO A ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. NØ. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE.
WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BRADFORD. DODD AYE. JONES
MENGIBAR. NGUYEN BERG. PADILLA.
AYE SKINNER SMILED. CUEVAS.
WAHAB. NGUYEN. NØ. ON A VOTE OF
THE ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 68. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 1458 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1458 BY SENATOR
ALLEN. AN ACT RELATING TO
ESTATES. SENATOR ALLEN. MEMBERS
SB 1458 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
IT UPDATES THE TRUST AND ESTATES
SECTION OF CODE RELATING TO
DIGITAL ASSETS. THERE WERE SOME
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY. IT'S RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER BLAKESBERG. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE.
DARAZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
OR, DATO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OKOBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. AYE.
SKINNER SMILED. CUEVAS STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. BECKER
BRADFORD. JONES MENJIVAR. OCHOA.
BOGUE SKINNER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WAHAB. SHE JUST WANTED
ONE. YES. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST
TIME. ATKINS BECKER. BRADFORD
JONES. MENGIBAR OCHOA. BOGUE. I
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WAHAB. ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 0, THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS. THE PLAN
FOR THIS MORNING IS TO TAKE UP
SEVEN ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
BILLS SEVEN, FOLLOWED BY A TWO
DIFFERENT CONSENT CALENDARS. SO
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH AND
THE ORDER IS THE GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM 106, FOLLOWED BY
132, 136 AND 144. THE FIRST ONE
UP IS FILE ITEM 106. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL 3130 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 3130
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR MANAGERS. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. SENATOR ARCHULETA,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MR. MONNING, PLEASE,
PLEASE GIVE THE SENATOR YOUR
ATTENTION. PLEASE. MEMBERS THERE
YOU GO. OKAY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 3130 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK-SILVA.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3130 PROMOTES
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BY REQUIRING BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS TO DISCLOSE CERTAIN
RELATIONSHIPS BEFORE ALLOCATING
PUBLIC FUNDS TO NONPROFITS AND
ORGANIZATIONS. CONFLICT OF
INTEREST LAWS ARE FOUNDED ON THE
PRINCIPLE THAT GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS MUST PLACE PUBLIC
INTERESTS ABOVE ALL AND OTHER
CONCERNS. EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS
A PUBLIC OFFICIAL FROM TAKING
PART IN GOVERNMENTAL DECISIONS
THAT WILL IMPACT THEIR PERSONAL
FINANCES. AB 3130 IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL THAT VALUES
TRUST, INTEGRITY AND FAIRNESS IN
THE ALLOCATION OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
DID JONES WALK ON THE FLOOR?
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. ALL RIGHT.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DAWLEY DODD. AYE. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. OTERO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NEELO.
AYE. OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. AYE. SKINNER SMILED.
CUEVAS. STERN AYE. UMBERG WAHAB.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
AYE ATKINS. BECKER BRADFORD.
DALLEY AYE. MENGIBAR. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 0. THE
MEASURE PASSES AND WE MAY HAVE
ESTABLISHED A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL THAT WE MAY USE FOR ANOTHER
MEASURE DOWN THE ROAD. ALL
RIGHT, NEXT UP, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM 132.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1978 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANCHEZ.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1978 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANCHEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR WILKINS
PRESENTING SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS
AB 1978 WILL GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ANOTHER
TOOL TO CRACK DOWN ON DANGEROUS
SIDESHOWS. SPECIFICALLY, THE
BILL WILL ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SEIZE A VEHICLE THAT BLOCKS A
ROAD FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FACILITATING STREET RACES OR
SIDESHOWS WITHOUT NEEDING TO
TAKE THE OWNER OF THE VEHICLE
INTO CUSTODY. PASSING THIS BILL
WILL HELP REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
DRIVERS NEEDLESSLY, NEEDLESSLY
ENDANGERING OTHERS AND
THEMSELVES ON THE ROADWAYS. THE
MEASURE HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION? IT
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES
33. NO'S ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP. FILE ITEM 136.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2164 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2164 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS. SENATOR EGGMAN.
PRESENTING. SEN. EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2164
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. THIS WILL JUST SAY
SIMPLY THAT PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
UNDERGOING TREATMENT FOR SOME
KIND OF ISSUE THAT DOES NOT
AFFECT THEIR PRACTICE DOES NOT
HAVE TO REPORT THAT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD. WE ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO GET TREATMENT. AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE YES. THANK
YOU. SENATOR EGGMAN, IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE?
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES 33.
NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 136. EXCUSE ME. FILE ITEM
144. IT'S THE ASSEMBLY BILL
2436. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2436 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING
TO CATTLE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFOR SENATOR
GROVE IS PRESENTING SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AB 2436 IS AN
INDUSTRY SUPPORTED MEASURE THAT
AIMS TO ENSURE THE BUREAU OF
LIVESTOCK IDENTIFICATION CAN
CONTINUE ITS IMPORTANT LIVESTOCK
INSPECTIONS. THE BILL WILL
ADJUST FEES AND MATCH TO MATCH
RISING COSTS, KEEP THE BUREAU'S
OPERATIONS FINANCIALLY STABLE.
THE BUREAU OF LIVESTOCK
IDENTIFICATION, UNDER CDFA IS
FULLY FUNDED BY BRAND
REGISTRATION FEES AND LIVESTOCK
INSPECTION FEES. RECENT COSTS
HAVE SURGED DUE TO INFLATION,
HIGHER WAGES. THE BOARD FOR
BRAND INSPECTORS AND THE SWITCH
TO ELECTRIC FLEET, WHICH TO
SUPPORT THE STATE'S CLIMATE
OBJECTIVES AND OTHER ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES. THE AB 2436 WILL
ENABLE THE BUREAU TO CONTINUE
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA CATTLE
PRODUCERS. LET US CONTINUE TO
EAT BEEF AND HAVE BEEF FOR
DINNER AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES 30
300. THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
292. ASSEMBLY BILL, 2004.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2004 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. AN ACT RELATING
TO RECORDS. SENATOR PORTANTINO
PRESENTING SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
2004 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WHICH IS A
CLEAN UP TO SB 696, WHICH I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR, SB 696
ESTABLISHED A LEGAL FRAMEWORK
FOR REMOTE ONLINE NOTARIZATION
THAT WOULD BE SAFE AND
CONVENIENT. UNFORTUNATELY, NOT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES CAN
ACCEPT ONLINE NOTARIZED
DOCUMENTS. AB 2004 CLARIFIES
THAT ALL 58 COUNTIES MAY ACCEPT
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ELECTRONICALLY NOTARIZED. THE
BILL ALSO INCLUDES LANGUAGE FOR
PROVIDING A CURE PERIOD, WHERE
MINOR TECHNICAL DEFECTS MAY BE
FIXED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PORTANTINO, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES
33. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 346. ASSEMBLY BILL 3179.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3079 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUAN CARRILLO. AN ACT RELATING
TO AIR POLLUTION. SENATOR
HURTADO, PLEASE GIVE HER YOUR
ATTENTION. MEMBERS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
AB 3179 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO. AB 3079 IS
A NECESSARY MEASURE THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR A NARROW EXEMPTION
SPECIFICALLY FOR BUCKET TRUCKS
AND CELL ON WHEELS TO THE CARB
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET
REGULATIONS. THIS BILL HAS NO NO
VOTES TO SUPPORT SUPPORT, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
HURTADO, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE,
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
EXCUSE ME. ALL RIGHT. WE ARE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL ON THIS
MEASURE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GIL
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE.
TARRAZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
AYE. OR DATO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN AYE. NHIÀU. AYE TROBOK.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER SMALL.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. BECKER BRADFORD. CORTEZ
AYE. GONZALEZ JONES. AYE
MINJIBIR. SKINNER SMALL. CUEVAS.
WAHAB ON A VOTE OF 32 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 497,
FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM 84 497 IS
AB 3184. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3184 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER
IS FLOOR MANAGER FOR THIS
MEASURE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 3184 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. IN OUR
LAST GENERAL ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER OF 2022, NEARLY 50% OF
REJECTED VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
WERE FOR EITHER A MISSING OR
NON-MATCHING SIGNATURE. IT WAS
NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
BALLOTS. NEARLY 60,000 BALLOTS
WERE MISSING OR NON-MATCHING
SIGNATURES. AB 3184 WOULD
PROVIDE GREATER OPPORTUNITY FOR
VOTERS TO CURE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT SIGNATURE ISSUES. THIS
NOVEMBER IN ORDER TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE HEARD AND THEIR VOTE
COUNTED. RIGHT NOW, IF THERE IS
A MISMATCHING OR MISSING
SIGNATURE ON THE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT ENVELOPE, OUR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS NOTIFY THE VOTER OF
THE PROBLEM. HOW TO CORRECT IT,
AND THAT THE VOTER HAS UNTIL 5
P.M. TWO DAYS PRIOR TO THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE ELECTION.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT VOTERS MAY
NOT KNOW WHEN A COUNTY IS GOING
TO CERTIFY THE ELECTION, AND
THEY MAY DO THE WORK TO CORRECT
THE DEFICIENCY, ONLY TO FIND
THAT THEY WERE TOO LATE. AB 3184
WOULD SPECIFY THAT COUNTIES
CANNOT CERTIFY THE ELECTION
RESULTS UNTIL THE 28TH DAY AFTER
THE ELECTION, AND THAT VOTERS
AND CAMPAIGNS HAVE UNTIL THE
26TH DAY TO FIX SIGNATURE
ISSUES. THIS MAXIMIZES THE TIME
TO CORRECT A SIGNATURE ISSUE AND
ENSURES THAT THE VOTE IS
COUNTED. IT ALSO PROVIDES A DATE
CERTAIN SO THAT EVERYONE IS
OPERATING UNDER THE SAME RULES.
THE BILL RETAINS ITS PREVIOUS
CONTENT ON BALLOT REJECTION
REPORTS AND ALSO INCLUDES
SEVERAL LARGELY TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO IMPROVE THE BALLOT
CURE PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE. MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
MEASURE? ALL RIGHT. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYE'S
30. EXCUSE ME. THERE IS AN
OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT. THIS IS A
27 VOTE BILL. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS BECKER.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI
AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NILO
AYE. TURBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. SMALL.
CUEVAS. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BECKER. BRADFORD
MENGIBAR. NGUYEN SEYARTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WAHAB
THAT'S A VOTE OF 31 TO 0 ON THE
URGENCY. 31 ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 84.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2620.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2620 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAINS. AN ACT RELATING TO AGING.
SENATOR ROTH IS PRESENTING
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
FROM 25 TO 18 AND REQUIRES
COMMISSIONERS TO HAVE
PROFESSIONAL, LIVED OR ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCE RELATED TO AGING.
THIS IS A PRACTICAL BILL. THE
COMMISSION HAS HAD A STATUTORY
COMPOSITION OF 25 MEMBERS SINCE
ITS INCEPTION. DURING ITS
EXISTENCE, HOWEVER, IT HAS NEVER
HAD ALL COMMISSION SEATS
APPOINTED, AND QUORUM IS
DICTATED BY THE NUMBER OF THOSE
COMPRISED TO SERVE, INCLUDING
VACANCIES, MAKING IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO CONDUCT ANY
BUSINESS BY REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF SERVING COMMISSIONERS. THIS
ALLOWS THE COMMISSION TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND TO ACTUALLY CONDUCT ITS
BUSINESS RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 33. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THAT
COMPLETES OUR THIRD READING
BUSINESS FOR THIS MORNING. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES
ANY MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
MEASURE REMOVED FROM EITHER OF
THOSE TWO? CONSENT CALENDARS?
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ BOTH
CONSENT CALENDARS. ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION 1916. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 13 169.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
2032 15. SENATE BILL THREE 5756
939 1111 1117, 1156, 1195, 1240
1468 1518. SENATE RESOLUTION 93.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 80.
SENATE RESOLUTION 118. 119 ONE
2125. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE 3198.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
151 128 213 TWO 2221 222 223 225
228 229. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDARS. ALLEN I RODA-GIL
ARCHULETA, I, ASHBY I ATKINS.
BECKER BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I. DALY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NILO I OKOBO I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SEYARTO I SKINNER. SMALL CUEVAS
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB WIENER I
WILK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO I ATKINS.
BECKER. BRADFORD GROVE I
MENJIVAR NGUYEN I SKINNER SMILED.
CUEVAS. WAHAB ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
A VOTE OF 33 TO 0 ON FILE ITEM
555. AND WE'LL APPLY THAT SAME
VOTE TO THE REMAINDER OF THE OF
BOTH CONSENT CALENDARS. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES, AND WE WILL RECOGNIZE
THE MAJORITY LEADER. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING THE BAFF-R
COMMITTEE TO OFFER AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO THE BUDGET BILL
AND BUDGET TRAILER BILLS LISTED
IN THE SENATE DAILY FILE FOR
AUGUST 26, 2020 FOR. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS MADE A
MOTION TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES. IT'S A NON-DEBATABLE
MOTION, BUT I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR NIELLO. FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE?
NIELLO? THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND FOR THE
ADMONITION ON BEHALF OF THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA WHO VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY FOR US TO PASS
THE BUDGET AS OF THE 15TH OF
JUNE, I OBJECT TO THIS MOTION.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR GONZALEZ'S
MOTION IS ON THE FLOOR TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES. SORRY.
AFTERWARDS SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO
GILL. NO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALI NO. DODD.
AYE DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO NIHILO.
NO OKOBO. NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH
A RUBIO. SATO NO. SKINNER.
SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE WAHAB. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. BECKER. BRADFORD
MENGIBAR. RUBIO. AYE SKINNER.
SMALL. CUEVAS WAHAB. ON A VOTE
OF 3024 TO 9, THE SENATE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. WE'LL CONTINUE
WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
RECOGNITION. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I MOVE
THE ADOPTION OF AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS FOR BUDGET BILLS AND
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS THAT
CROSSED THE DESK ON FRIDAY,
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY, AUGUST 23RD
THROUGH THE 25TH, 2024. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED,
PUBLISHED AND THE BILLS RETURN
TO COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS? ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE AN OBJECTION TO USING
THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL? MISS
JONES, IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL?
OKAY, SO ON A VOTE OF 24 TO 9,
THE MOTION TO AMEND IS ADOPTED.
MOTION CARRIES. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO SENATOR
ASHBY. YOUR MICROPHONE IS UP.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
PULL FILE ITEM A18, WHICH IS AB
274 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT.
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE, THE DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR HURTADO UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. CAN YOU
PLEASE MOVE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR? AB 2348 FOR Ã TO
THIRD READING. FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS, THE DESK WILL NOTE
ANY FURTHER RECOGNITIONS HERE.
NOT SEEING ANY. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO COMMITTEE
AND ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. LOOKING FOR
SENATOR DODD.
MR. PRESIDENT, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, UPON ADJOURNMENT,
ROOM 2200. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DODD. ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT,
MEMBERS, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO ENCOURAGE FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO HYDRATE THIS
WEEKEND, GET SOME REST, MAYBE A
MASSAGE OR TWO, BECAUSE NEXT
WEEK IS GOING TO BE A LONG WEEK.
I WANT TO REMIND FOLKS MONDAY
WE'RE GOING. WE'LL GET OUT
BEFORE MIDNIGHT, BUT WE'RE GOING
LATE TUESDAY. WEDNESDAY FOLKS
SHOULD ANTICIPATE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE HERE BETWEEN 11 AND
MIDNIGHT ON TUESDAY, WEDNESDAY.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO SPENDING
SOME QUALITY TIME WITH EACH
OTHER NEXT WEEK. I KNOW THAT
EVERYBODY WILL BE TURNING THEIR
FROWNS UPSIDE DOWN AND INTO A
SMILE. THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY, AUGUST
26TH AT 2 P.M. LOOK FORWARD. MR.
PRESIDENT, TO NEXT WEEK. THANK
YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE, FOR THAT
GREAT NEWS. THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY, AUGUST 26TH AT
2 P.M.